[Music]
the dragon's run is the 10th chapter of
ursula k le guin's third earth sea novel
the farthest shore it's also a location
that we're going to talk about in just a
moment looking at her vivid description
of it and as you can guess it is where
dragons live many many dragons as a
matter of fact this is the
largest group concentration whatever we
want to call it of dragons that we have
in the earth sea
novels up to this point we've
encountered dragons prior to this in a
story and in the first novel but this is
a lot more dragons and the dragons as
it's going to turn out in this chapter
are in a bad way
so let's talk first about the geography
of this place so the dragon's run is an
entire set of islands that are south and
east of celador the place where the the
climax of the story is going to take
place or at least a gateway into the the
dry land where it will take place
and there's a really interesting
description
here
there was no man living who had sailed
the dragon's run or seen it except the
ark mage at that point 20 years before
and more he had sailed the length of it
from east to west and back again it was
a nightmare and a marvel to a sailor
the water was a maze of blue channels
and green shoals and among these by hand
in worded most vigilant care he and
aaron now pick their boats way between
the rocks and reefs some of these lay
low under or half under the wash of the
waves covered with anemone and barnacle
and ribbony seaford like water monsters
shelled or sinuous others stood up in
cliff and pinnacles shear from the sea
and these were arches and half arches
carving towers fantastic shapes of
animals boars backs and serpents heads
all huge deformed diffuse as if life
arrived half conscious on the rock
the sea waves beat on them with a sound
like breathing and they were wet with
the bright bitter spray and one such
rock from the south there was plainly
visible the hunch shoulders and heavy
noble head of a man stooped and
pondering thought above the sea
but when the boat had passed it looking
back from the north all man was gone
from it and the massive rocks revealed a
cave in which the sea rose and fell
making a hollow clapping thunder iron
said is there a voice in the cave and
god says the sea's voice but it speaks a
word sparrowhawk listened and he glanced
at iron back of the cave how do you hear
it
as saying the sound am
in the old speech that signifies the
beginning or long ago but i hear it as
ob which is a way of saying the end so
there's this you know very interesting
place that they're in and it you know
it's kind of a magical
fantastical place just exactly the sort
of thing where you would think to find
dragons
and they see the dragons
they the dragons come out
to
meet them
and this is something that
um
aaron or lebanon has been yearning
to see
because of all the things that are said
about dragons ghett has seen them many
times right uh he's he's uh not bored
with them but he's he's not as betaken
with them as you can say
so there's this brilliant description
here as look far approached the islands
aaron saw the dragons soaring and
circling on the morning wind and his
heart lipped up with them with a joy
a joy of fulfillment that was like pain
what a great description of the
affectivity of seeing
this this sight of dragons flying
leguin has another thing that she says
that she puts in iron's mind
at this point
all the glory of mortality
was in that flight
all the glory of mortality was in that
flight of the dragons
what a statement why why is that the
case and here is where we get to
something
deeply
philosophical
where metaphysics and morals
and aesthetics intersect
it goes on their beauty was made up of
terrible strength
utter wildness
and the grace of reason so things that
we wouldn't think to put together
wildness reason
right there's an explanation for these
were thinking creatures
with speech and ancient wisdom
in the pattern of their flight there was
a fierce willed
concord
so
why is it so awesome to see the dragons
it's not just you're seeing these things
flying around which is beautiful by
itself if you've ever seen you know
birds of prey flying or things along
those lines you might be able to relate
to that or the grace of a great cat
hunting or anything along those lines
this is something
different
their their rationality
their fact of thinking
the
connection between them and language is
somehow manifest in this flight
now there's something that needs to be
explored here something that needs to be
unpacked that leguin is not telling us
here
aristotle provides a good example of
this in politics book one but there are
many other philosophers
both in
you know greece and rome and in other
parts of the world who have connected
this
or called to mind this interconnection
between
speech language
and
reasoning the capacity to
think the capacity to respond in
rational ways aristotle says that
we are different than the other animals
in that they do in fact communicate with
each other in some ways they make sounds
but they don't have logos they don't
have reason or speech and it's because
of that that we can have koinonia that
is sharings or community it's also
because of that that we can use rhetoric
back in the wizard of earth see we find
out dragons can lie using the old speech
right they can make things seem to be
what they're not and
vice versa
and we also can
not just talk about but perceive things
that other animals can't for example the
beautiful and the ugly the
or the noble and the fine the
um
the just and the unjust and aristotle
says all the other moral qualities kai
to allah greek something like this is
being
gestured at by the green here in in
iron's response to
the dragons notice that ged is not
explaining this arin grasps this as
something central now we also find out
that the dragon's flight is disordered
in certain respects it they are angered
and ged goes on and says
they're angry they dance their anger on
the wind now we're in the hornet's nest
and dead cries aloud to them a sort of
greeting
and there are three different responses
by the dragons some of them are like oh
i get it
this guy's on our side and they fly back
off to the islands to
leave him alone uh he says some of them
wheeled in mid-flight scattering and
returned to the aisles others
halted and hovered
the sword-like claws with their forearms
outstretched but checked they're waiting
to see what's going to happen
and then he says one dropping low over
the water flew slowly on towards them
and two wing strokes it was over the
boat the male belly scarcely cleared the
mast aaron saw the wrinkled armor and
unarmored flush between the inner
shoulder joint and breast which with the
eye is the dragon's only vulnerable
point the smoke that roiled from the
long toothed mouth choked him with it
came a carrion stench that made him
wince and ratch
and they're actually being singed by
both gad and aaron so this is like a
buzzing attack right
and they're wondering why
so sparrowhack says
there was an insult that was an
insolence but i seek no quarrel with
these creatures they seem mad or
bewildered they did not speak
never have i met a dragon who did not
speak before it struck if only to
torment
its prey
what is going on here
and we actually get the explanation
um
from you know ormbar in just a bit but
before that they run across
an evil site they call it
something bad
a dying dragon
a dragon who is not dying of disease or
hunger or something like that
instead
it's
dying because of the wounds that have
been inflicted on it by the other
dragons
it says
one black wing was bent under it the
other stretched out vast across the sand
and into the water so that the come and
go of waves moved it a little into and
fro in a mockery of flight the long
snake body lay full length on the rock
and sand one foreleg was missing the
armor and flesh were torn from the great
arch of the ribs and the belly was torn
open so that the sand for yards was
blackened with the poison dragon blood
yet the creatures still lived so great a
life is in dragons that only an equal
power of wizardry can kill them swiftly
the green gold eyes were open and as the
boat sailed by the lean huge head moved
a little and with a rattling hiss steam
mixed with bloody spray shot from the
nostrils the beach between the dying
dragon and the sea's edge was tracked
and scored by the feet and heavy bodies
of his kind and his entrails were
trodden into the sand so other dragons
did that to him
why
so sparrowhawk has a conjecture he says
they've been driven mad their speech has
been taken from them those who spoke
before men spoke who are older than any
other living being the children of segoy
they have been driven to the dumb terror
of the beasts so
this this faculty uh which for them is
not just you know a language that they
happen to learn the way
people in earth see do
the language of the making has been
taken from them the true speech
the language of creation that they
learned without even having to engage in
any education whatsoever if they're born
into it
that has been taken from them it would
be as if you took
something absolutely intimate and
essential to all of us away from us that
despair that they're in
now
we find from orm embar who at that point
has not yet lost his own speech
what has taken place another dragon lord
has come one who may in fact be stronger
than all of the dragons
and ged himself
and ged reports to aaron what embar has
has uh said
he said this man has been among them
having no fear of them for though he
though killed he returns from death in
his body
alive therefore they fear him as a
creature outside nature so
this this mage this wizard this dragon
lord doesn't show fear to them
and he keeps coming back in a new body
whenever they kill him so the fear is
reversed and because they fear him
he has power over them and what does he
do with that power he takes from them
something that is most intimate
and essential to them their voices their
speech
they remain dragons they still have
their massive bodies they still have the
magic that they're created by they still
have incredible power
but they can't communicate with each
other and they can't talk even to
themselves they're missing something and
this has greatly disordered them
says he takes the speech of the making
from them leaving them pray
to their own wild nature so they devour
one another or take their own lives
plunging into the sea a loathly death
for the fire serpent the beast of wind
and fire
so this is a
really significant problem it's not just
the human beings of the vast archipelago
of earthsea that are in a bad way the
magic failing the luck failing joy
failing
disorder arising
it's now also the great race of the
dragons as well but not all of them
orm embar at this point still has his
name ged asks where are you collecting
the oldest of all the dragons as we're
going to find out colosseum retains his
speech
as well
so all is not lost but it's looking
pretty bad at this point in the
encounter with the dragons of the run
you